mafia states of america which is this
whole project that we've been working on
i think
why don't we get into that a little bit
do we want to finish with that or do we
want to get into that we can
don't bury them right now don't bury the
lead go ready
so look
you know
uh michael and sammy okay this sit down
everybody kept asking me is this gonna
happen is this gonna happen it's not
gonna happen is it eventually gonna be
where these guys gonna sit together i'll
tell you my story of what happened
behind closers you've been a project
obviously you've been the director of
the project
from beginning to the end
sammy and i had a conversation two years
ago when sammy first got out of jail and
i said hey sammy how you doing he says
you the guy that interviewed michael
francis i said yes is what tough and
have an interview was this two and a
half hours he just went trashing michael
and i'm like listen sammy all i want to
do is why don't you and i get sick i
wouldn't get together with nobody
so anyways going back and forth your
month goes by two months three months
six months we follow up i said why don't
i just come by and you and i sit down
and visit no
great so every time no no
nine months later he agrees so we go to
phoenix me and mario hey let's go have a
sit down with sammy
and uh so i want you to meet me at this
location we go to this one location guy
comes outside he picks us up we walk all
the way to the back of the building you
walk and you walk and you walk in at the
end of it mario's like listen it's
getting a little too deep of a walk it's
getting darker we get all the way to the
end and then boom
there's semi-developed gravano we sit
down
a couple hours we're talking you know he
shares his thoughts he says let me think
about it what we're going to do then we
finally do the interview at pops 12
million views
short clips everything together 25
million views
and then at the end of the interview i'm
like you know sam you know what be great
what be great if you and michael sat
down together what did you say me and
michael never happened i'd never it's
okay now i go to michael and i presented
mike mike so i'm not going to do it so
they've gone back and forth calling each
other uh behind closers i'm trying to
see if we can make this happen or not i
understand why they wouldn't want to
meet with each other because two
different families
finally
finally they agreed and we met in a
undisclosed location security the whole
nine you couldn't find where we were at
you know where we can't even tell the
location right now but
we went to this place we sat down how
many hours of footage do we have by the
way
of them talking actually yeah of them
the two of them 15 hours 16 hours 16
hours 16 hours of them talking about
them just so imagine like a 16 hour
podcast is what it is
so we came back then we have giuliani
how many hours was julian three and
three hours three at his place no that's
three hours on camera you guys chatted
for like another two hours off camera
what what are some how crazy were some
of the things rudy said honestly it like
to the point where uh
we were concerned if we could put it out
some of the stuff we don't know if we
can put out of what rudy said some of
the stuff we can i know a lot of people
can say put the whole thing out we
definitely cannot put the whole thing
out i can tell you we own the footage on
youtube no yeah probably not on youtube
and by the way some of the stuff that
michael and sammy said we may not be
able to put on youtube but uh a lot of
people have been asking about when is
this coming out and you know chas
palmentary legendary actor you know
bronx tale all of these things he's also
in it he absolutely crushed him by the
way he was a writer as we helped write
he did yeah a big part of it with you
you guys were co-writing together yeah
it was awesome uh so it was a great
experience the question everyone's
asking is when is this coming up we
let the teaser out
which people are furious well are you
are you ready to announce the release
date i don't know i can tell you when
it's ready
i don't know if we're gonna oh that's a
release date yet i think we maybe let
the trailer do fair enough it's part by
friday but i can't want to tease the
release date it ain't coming out for
four to six weeks okay i can take it for
a fact it ain't coming up for four to
six weeks so hang in there there's a lot
of pissed off people right now on
twitter youtube everywhere saying why
don't you do this to us why isn't it
coming out tomorrow it ain't coming up
for four or six years okay but it's
going to be coming out soon and and the
topics are some topics you for about
four to five weeks we're thinking about
doing two episodes every week for four
to five weeks the world is going to stop
for four to five weeks each week it's
going to be two episodes we'll premiere
and they're going to be glued to the
screen people sitting down together with
popcorn remember how we did the last
stance i was just going to say this is
very eerie of the last dance and
the mafia right completely unscripted
yeah completely
just to be clear when pat's talking
about writing we're talking about
narration we're talking about writing
the ins and the outs there's absolutely
nothing that that was said there's
nothing that that was uh
that was orchestrated here and this is
this is as real and uncertain
like there was there was not one part
where we said hey michael can you say
that one more time hey sammy can you say
that one more time like if they're going
back and forth with each other and they
were having a discussion about something
hey can we get another cut on this sami
say that one more time none of that
when's the last time they even sat in a
room together
yeah can i tell a story about what
almost happened or do you want to save
it for behind the scenes which part
which store
when we when we got there the whole
everything was set
go for it you tell it you tell it dude
so here here we are we've we've flown
a 30-person crew halfway around the
world all right and
we've got pat's got a hundred thousand
dollars worth of gear and an entire crew
set we got there four hours early we we
took this castle and we turned it into a
set and then we're waiting waiting
waiting on set waiting for talent
waiting for talent waiting for talent
and they were still negotiating
whether or not they were going to do
this past call time they were supposed
to be on in a separate room 9am the two
of them are with michael's team and
samus team and me and mario you must
i don't i mean you you're a business guy
so you like this stuff my balls would
have been in my throat i got a i got 200
000 worth of loss sitting 50 yards away
it's not done by the way dude i what did
i tell you i was like what are you doing
what are we doing what did you not have
a contract
what the hell are we doing here man like
did you just jump out of an airplane and
hope somebody threw down a parachute
like what the hell happened right here
but chris and by the way this entire
time i'm talking to rudy giuliani we're
going back and forth rudy rudy's pissed
off we're trying to make it work with he
was supposed to fly yeah i mean
we'll talk about that later but that's a
completely different thing but and
rudy's the guy who brought down the mob
right that's the reason that you wanted
to have his own rudy has to be a part of
this so rudy yeah you have to realize
man outside everything that people say
with rudy and trump prior to rudy and
trump rudy was like the alpha man a top
10 alpha man of america
mayor of new york you know g-man award
whatever say what you want about rudy
the man save new york city i lived
through it the man saved new york city
well he was a hero in the 90s 4 000
people got it right 4 000 arrests uh uh
how many people over 100 years eight got
over 100 years some some ridiculous
number like what this guy did but back
to my original question when's the last
time sammy and michael actually sat down
and spoke but here's what you have to
realize
the last time made men sat down face to
face to do something like this you know
was the last time that happened it's
called never wow this has never happened
and if it's happened it's behind closed
doors never with cameras it's the first
time ever yeah where can and by the way
you have to realize there's a group of
people that are saying uh uh sammy's
gonna win the sit-down and there's a
group of people that are leaning towards
frenzies matter of fact we have a
website mafia states of america a lot of
unique merchants coming out a lot of
people are asking about autographs we're
going to be doing this poster mafia
states of america signed by michael
sammy limited edition it's probably
going to be only the first 100 or maybe
the first 500 that we'll do that comes
out where you're going to be able to put
that on the wall there are some that are
saying michael's going to win this sit
down there are some that are saying sami
is going to want to sit down and matter
of fact
i may
we if if michael or sammy are i got to
make this call to them as well we may
bring them on the podcast pre-release
individual we got to do it individually
obviously
we may bring michael and we'll have him
one week we may bring sammy the next
week on a podcast like this wow to
discuss their experience before this
gone live that'd be awesome that'd be
sick if we do that they're pretty heated
up man they had to
take a note of that make a note of that
for me to make the phone call afterwards
but what was nuts was like the history
more like the history of america more
than anything else like you don't even
have to be a mob fan you don't need to
have to be like a mafia that was going
to be my question actually is how does
this the normal part the stuff that they
talked about hoffa about kennedy the
stuff that they talked about i i don't
know how deep you want me to go into it
but like the joe banano book like this
dude it would like as a history buff as
a political aficionado mario cuomo came
up
mario cuomo came up by both giuliani and
frenzies
and uh gravano he's the italian governor
of new york i mean apparently what what
everybody said the affiliation with the
mob
so mario was apparently connected
giuliani said i won't release i'll let
them tell the story and what it was but
it was it was very interesting on the
angle they took and how they felt about
andrew how they felt about mario cuomo
what role he played in the streets of
new york the level of respect
very very unique angle that they took
and then there was a couple parts where
you know
they talked about how all the industries
that were part of that was illegal now
they're multi-billion dollar industries
you have to hear how they explain it
like how they trained the u.s government
to do it like they trained essentially
their strategies and tactics are being
used today by the us government and are
being used today by fortune 500
companies that's why it's called
mafia states of america right the whole
idea is we trained the mafia united
states they were part of it like think
about bank of america you know bank of
america used to be bank of italy
no if you go look did you know this or
no hey kai can somebody come up here
jump on wikipedia real quick type in
wikipedia bank of america
kai stepped out if you can come up here
bank of america before bank of america
became bank of america was bank of italy
you have no idea no no type in bank of
america
hey there's david
type and bank of america dave by the way
david how you doing doing well good all
right good
he's been waiting for this moment for
weeks no man david's uh ever since okay
go wikipedia go wikipedia go down to
wikipedia try to find bank of america go
lower
uh
wiki okay good uh typing the control f
italy
okay there you go right there right
there it shows right there uh uh one
branch of its history stretches back to
bank of italy founded by
bank of indonesian foreign bank of
america october 17 1904 down general
bank of it founded the bank of italy in
san francisco 19 now bank of america so
the whole thing started off with them
giving loans to town because back then
nobody would give italians loans
because they didn't think highly of
italians they thought like oh you know
there was names for italians just like
there's a lot of different names for
them
so they started off supporting them in
bank of italy early 1900s
the monstrosity that it is today so the
power
and the influence of the italian
community and the italian mob
is very much deep rooted in the history
of america the last hundred years i mean
really so wow you know when this thing
comes out everybody's right now talking
about you know
the biggest conversation is will
michael's approach win or will sammy's
approach win and there's a team frenzies
there's a team gravano two heavyweights
two heavyweights and what families are
they with
colombo and gambino yeah who's colombo
francis
and by the way
sammy was with he was before he was with
gambino he was with another family
colombo
and they they kind of made the trade you
know and they said hey you ain't going
to be able to work out over here and he
went to the gambino family and obviously
he became the underboss for john gotti
so can i ask you a a it's kind of a
weird question but it's in in the light
of the last dance right so
you know like i've seen good fellows i
was in casino i've got who doesn't love
these kind of movies right obviously
you've by the way kudos to you by the
way i mean
if you guys understood what gerard was
doing these guys sleeping on couches
over here just to get this job done the
whole team it's really impressive no
it's really impressive but for sort of
the layman
you know in the last dance
mold
is there a michael jordan of the mafia
who would sammy be who would france be
that question was asked i'm opening up a
can of worms here i get it who like who
are these characters in the
you know if to use the nba analogy would
you do something like that
listen i'll let them answer it because
they actually addressed that question
where you know who where michael said
who was the greatest the ghost lebron
came up and jordan came up and like
who's the greatest
gangster of all time and they were kind
of going back and forth saying who it
was who it wasn't
and i'll give you one interesting one
yeah rudy doesn't think it was an
italian rudy thinks it was a jewish guy
great well you know where that goes by
the way that only goes one side on where
this thing goes to meyer lansky where is
this yeah i mean meyer was meyer was
meyer you got the brain then they call
him the brain meyer was uh i don't know
you're feeling familiar with the jewish
community i've yeah i've known i know
i've known i've known a couple he's
legit i've known a couple brothers what
was ben
siegel of course you don't call them
foxy they say you can call them the jews
and the and the italians work together
uh very closely because at the end of
the day they said irish as well back in
the day it was all immigrants
italians got the jews cut so there was a
little bit of they related to each other
there was a certain anti-immigrant yeah
exactly so like to talk about that i
mean the the history of the mob is
really kind of the history of
immigration in america especially in
cities yeah the the jews were the og's
so like when you talk about um st
patrick's day and what do you think
saint patrick's do you think corned beef
cabbage
alcohol yeah i don't think alcohol is
true but the corn beef and cabbage had
there's no there's no corn beef and
cabbage in ireland that was something
that the the jewish like a settler as
well however you call them the original
jewish immigrants in new york city
they taught the irish immigrants
there was no refrigeration they taught
them how to salt their meat they told
them how to boil the cabbage so the corn
beef and cabbage is an irish immigrant
remembrance from when they came over
here and they were they were second
class third class citizens you can look
at i mean if people want to really go
deep into the history of like i'm irish
obviously this matters to me but if you
want to go deep into the history you can
look and it says no color no irish
applied they were actually called irish
n-words if you google it you know
there's a whole harper's bazaar where
they they were they were thought of as
you know the the the northern black so
by the way here here's the other part
about this that's a
interesting point you're making the one
interesting part about this whole thing
that's going on with uh sammy and
michael
is there's a big community that doesn't
want to see this go live oh i'm sure
there's people that do not want this oh
i mean the emails and the calls we're
getting there's a big community that's
not happy about this the dms privately
coming to us there is a massive
community that does not want to see this
thing take place a massive community
share who is this community i can't i
can't i can't do of course
i can't even tell you like you know but
but it's connected to that life but
there's a big community that doesn't
want to see this become live because
hey you're talk telling a story two men
who have experience in this and
michael's dad wasn't just any
man he was sunny frenzies
55 years time in prison one of the most
feared
men in the streets of new york in the
streets of america he claims to have
been with
everybody and and this is not a guy that
brags about it one day i was in new york
driving around we spent a whole day
together i was trying to get him to do
an interview
wouldn't open up nothing that like that
guy
wouldn't say anything that's michael's
that's who trained michael so think
about
who trained michael it's sunny sunny
comes from the era of lucky
meyer costello 104 years old means you
were 20 years old in 1940.
yeah that's nice just think about that
you're 20 years old in the 30s how old
is he he died at 104 years old 103 years
old ago he died a year and a half ago
wow so he took everything to the grave
he took everything to the grave wouldn't
say anything i drove him i said hey tell
me about mayor lansky is it true he was
a billionaire he was a richest man he
says myra was a great man i said how
about lucky how about ben siegel he's
how about bugsy what do you think he
said don't call him bugs you can't call
him buxy you cannot call him bugs his
name is ben you call him ben siegel i
said how about ben siegel he says ben
siegel won the best man i ever did
business with i said are you kidding me
sonny the stories you read about ben
siegel what he did great man
i said sonny how about your story a lot
of people say you took a lot of people
out they said you were one of the most
feared men in the streets i was innocent
you know it's just like
so and then on sammy's side sammy's
bringing history sammy's still
loyal to the life he still is a gangster
like sammy's still today he may be free
but sami is not michael who was a
changed man so there is two different
worlds colliding
and there's communities on both sides
that don't want to sit down to take
place well i would tell you that you
know one of my concerns going into it
was i i kind of grew up in that
environment and my father hated the mob
my god and he hated him he thought these
guys were bullies and all this other
stuff and i was just like this to me is
interesting these are very very
interesting guys this is a we have to
document this isn't a part of american
history it's going away yeah we have to
document this right this is something
that this these are stories that need to
be told this is part of the fabric of
our society this is something that made
us who we are but i don't i didn't want
to i didn't want to glorify the crime i
didn't want i didn't want to do this
romanticized
because rudy rudy does not well this is
what i was going to say yeah the
the thing probably you did better than
anything else in producing this and
hosting it you pressed these guys this
was not a puff piece by any chance you
pressed these dudes on on every step of
the way you know like you know every
kind of excuse they gave you you pressed
back you pushed back why didn't you just
go legit obviously this model works you
should've been legit this is a different
different kind of an interview it's a
very technical interview because
you you know you would you would ask a
question we would go and go a little
deeper and then they went
and they went and and you know we're
sitting on extracting the best part to
put it in the jars on a great job
putting that together anyways i cannot
wait for the world to see this when this
premieres in the next four six eight
weeks and by the way
people who are upset about it listen we
can put it somewhere else and charge you
a hundred bucks if you're upset about it
or we can do it the right way because
this is all going on youtube here's a
question for you do you think a netflix
a hulu and amazon wants the rights to
this 30 hours of footage kidding me
they'll cut a multi-million auto check
easily we don't need the money for this
this is something i want the world to
see i want the world to see this so it's
going to be interesting to see
what happens with this we're going to
own the rise to this uh for as long as
you know valuetainment can't hold the
rights to this i mean this is a this is
going to be the first biggest project
where we put a good amount of money into
which have a half a million dollars at
this point
into to make this happen this
history
ever it's not even close
this is creating history i mean it's
yeah and the the
the production value look i i we're
working hard on a man but i think the
people are gonna love it i really do
yeah it's it's
last thing before we move on i'm just
talking about the teaser that went out
it was what a minute long how long was
it 50 seconds 47 seconds awesome
captivating chaz comes in this is a true
story this isn't amazing right you're
captivated and like the the line that
the first line you really hear sammy say
to michael
and this is what i want you guys to
explain is like what happened to omerta
and you [ __ ] did this
and and like
just and you said sammy's still in that
like just explain that the omerta and
the whole thing with that and sunny not
speaking but you got to realize sammy's
still a gangster
sammy is still again and sammy called
michael out hardcore
i mean sammy called michael out it was a
direct call out and michael didn't back
down and they went head to head like
there's certain areas like you'll see
michael you're like well michael you
know just kind of it's probably going to
be passive in that area michael pushed
back
and there are certain areas where sami
is just brutal zero filters again for
the people that have followed these
stories they're going to be glued to the
screen and it's very technical because
in the world of the mob it is a very
technical conversation yet at the same
time they're both good storytellers so
you're hearing it from
you know two men who have been able to
sit down with some of the most powerful
people on the mob last however many
years yeah it's going to be pat how many
hours have you spent speaking sitting
down with with the mob i mean at this
point
you got to be some sort of made man
somewhat qualified exactly that's what i
was just going to say well look i i i
like i don't want to sound like a
salesman here but you got you do have to
go to mafia states of america because
you talk about omerta there's going to
be so many esoteric terms
uh that's also been an interesting part
of this is like these terms are terms i
grew up with i just assumed everybody
knew them and then you know our
production assistants you know like i'm
talking with like uh one of our
production assistants is like you know
20 21 year old latina girl from miami
and she's like she thought bensonhurst
was a guy she had no idea that was yeah
she was like i'm having it i'm having
her batch b-roll and she's like for the
life of me i can't find a picture of
this benson hurst i was like bensonhurst
in the part of brooklyn yeah are you
serious so like we we we're gonna have a
glossary of terms to get brushed up on
so you know what america is you know
what these places are you know we may we
may even afterwards do behind the scenes
because i think some people would want
to see some of the stuff that we did
behind this if we can get behind the
scenes put together people got to see
how this was behind closed doors because
all the other stuff is great it was
intense yeah it was intense anyway so
again stay tuned well congratulations
guys this is awesome
looks amazing six
eight weeks maybe ten we're trying to
get it closer to six stay tuned and by
the way here's what we may do here's
what we may do
we may after all the episodes have gone
live
we may host a live event with all the
parties involved in the q and a session
how are you going to get them to play
nice in the same way i have no idea but
we may do something figuring it out
along the way we may do something like
that like get a hall with it down maybe
do something here in florida
maybe we'll do like a fountain blue or
we'll take something you know a
neutral place and we'll go in and
audience will be able to buy tickets i
foresee those tickets selling out in no
time and we'll emcee it and host it and
bring them out and they think that's
what's good
man
you know what'd be funny is to see the
guest list the guest list will be fun
and the kind of security you need
to escort everybody
can we get access to the guest list
anyways all right so that's going to be
interesting stay tuned four six eight
weeks maybe ten weeks so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye
[Music]